the average couple has sex for anywhere
from 30 seconds to about 45 minutes now
45 minutes sounds long until you
consider the brown and tetanus for two
weeks every mating season a male will
mate as much as physically possibly
sometimes having sex for up to 14 hours
at a time
flitting from one female to the next and
all that testosterone revs up his stress
hormone production into overdrive
that in turn crashes his immune system
making him extremely vulnerable to
disease and infection often times he
dies before his young are even born
scientists call this kamikaze mating
technique suicidal reproduction it turns
out that for many species sex kills take
the male honeybee his primary job mate
with the Queen but sadly for him he only
gets to meet once because during the act
his reproductive organs are ripped off
and his testicles explode in the process
his semen shoots through her oviduct
where she stores it for later use
hey at least it's a quick death
especially compared to some deep-sea
anglerfish like the triple wart sea
devil this one's a female and you see
that tiny parasite on her side that's
the male it would be like if a human
male only came up to a woman's ankle
instead of hunting for his own food the
male bites into the female using his
body with hers and living off the
nutrients in her blood
in return he provides the one thing he
has to offer sperm but there's a catch
in the process his body shrivels up he
loses his eyes fins and most internal
organs until ultimately he becomes just
a portable sperm bank for the female
fortunately not all males have it that
rough the short beak echidna survives
meeting but his sex life is anything but
ordinary
he'll line up with around nine other
males and follow a single female for up
to a month during mating season but
here's the interesting part
females have a forked reproductive tract
but that doesn't deter the males because
they have a four-headed penis so during
sex the male alternates swapping out
spent pairs as each fires its semen and
that semen is supercharged hundreds of
sperm glom together into bundles which
can swim faster than individual sperm
increasing their chance of fertilization
if that's not impressive enough his
penis reaches nearly a quarter of his
body length when erect but that's
nothing compared to a barnacles that
little crustacean has proportionally the
longest penis of any animal on earth
spanning up to ten times his body size
that's like humans reaching the length
of a bowling lane and the barnacle needs
it because he can't move around very
easily so we cast out his giant penis
like a fishing line to find a mate
it waves about in the current reaching
to touch and fertilize the female organs
of its neighbor B or Barnacle
reproduction finds creative ways to
continue on
[Music]